[موسيقى]
دعا الامين العام للاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل نور الدين الطبوبي السلطات التونسيه
الى ما سماها التشاركيه والابتعاد عن
سياسات الاستهداف كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا
في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نقرا مطالبات
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل السلطه
التونسيه بتطبيق اتفاقاتها المسبقه مع
الاتحاد وكيف تستقبل السلطات التونسيه
مطالبات الاتحاد العام للشغل وقوى سياسيه
بفتح باب الحوار وما هي افاق الخروج من
الازمه السياسيه التي تشهدها
[موسيقى]
البلاد الاسباب بطبيعه الحال فيها اسباب
موضوعيه وفي اسباب شخصيه هناك اسباب
موضوعيه ممكن تتعلق ببعض القافات التي تمت
لبعض النقابيين في فتره ما منذ تقريب خمسه
وست اشهر وراينا كيف ان الاتحاد بدا ولوح
بحرب استنزاف ضد السلطه من اجل ايقاف هذا
هذه الايقافات المتكرره التي طالت بعض
النقابيين وكان الاتحاد في كل مره يهدد
بان صائف ستنتهي وانه سيشرع ابتداء من
بدايه السنه في المطالبه بحقوقه ومن جر
عنها من مطالبات بطبيعه الحال تتعلق
بالاتفاقيات السابقه التي تمت مع الدوله
والتي يقول الاتحاد انه لم يتم تنفيذها
وان الدوله ماطلت وتخاذل في ذلك اسباب
شخصيه بحته ممكن شخصيه بالمعنى الاك
المعنى العلمي التحليلي وهي التي تحيلنا
الى ان الاتحاد يعني قالق جدا بخصوص ما
يسميه هو على لسانه انفراد السلطه لنفسها
بنفسها وعدم تشاركتها مع الاتحاد ومكوناته
لا الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل وعلى راسه
المكتب التنفيذي والامين العام السيد نور
الدين الطبوبي ادركوا تماما ان بين ظفرين
ان صحت الكلمه بدور
التجريف مع مسار 25 جويليه وبقيا الرئيس
قيس سعيد سيصل الى ساحه محمد علي يعني الى
مقر الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل وان رئيس
الجمهوريه غير معني ابدا باي شراكه حتى مع
الذين وضعوا انفسهم تحت سقف 25 جويليه وقد
جرب الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل على
امتداد السنتين الفارط التين رفع ان شئنا
خطاب الاحتجاج بين ظفرين على انفراد رئيس
الجمهوريه بهذا المسار وكان الجواب عاصفا
من طرف السلطه بان وضعت الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل في الزاويه واعلنت بطريقه
غير مباشره انها مستعده لكي تفتح ايضا
ملفاته ما داب عليه الاتحاد و اكبر منظمه
في تونس ونحترمه جله داب على ثلاث
اتفاقيات ضمن يعني الاتفاقيات اتفاقيات
الشراكه مع السلطه القائمه في عهد الباجي
ق السبسي وفشلت كل الاتفاقيات التي ابرمت
بقرطاج وادت الى ما نحن
عليه يعني هناك فكره عامه سائده لدى
الجميع ان الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
ساهم على امتداد ع سنوات في اعاقه
الانتقال الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي و انجز العديد من الاضرابات
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل يدرك ان
صورته في اوساط الشعب التونسي ليست بالقدر
الذي يجعله قادرا الان على ان يرفع صوته
للاحتجاج والشراكه السياسيه مع السلطه
قائمه ايضا الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
يدرك ان الرعاه الدوليين دعني اقول
للتجربه الانتقاليه في تونس وللثوره ولانت
قال الديمقراطي يحملونه هو وجزء كبير من
المجتمع المدني مسؤوليه التصعيد ومسؤوليه
التعفير ومسؤوليه التعطيل التي مورث في
علاقه بالاحزاب والحكومات المختلفه التي
تعاقبت على حكم البلاد ولم تتعاون لمنظمه
منظمه الاتحاد لم تتعاون مع الحكومات
المختلفه لكي تجد ارضيه للاصلاح الذي كان
يمكن ان يغني البلاد عن الالتجاء الى
حادثه 25 جويل ونعلم ان الحكومه قامت
بعديد المفاوضات مع الاتحاد السنه هذه
والسنه الفاره وادت الى زياده في اجور
القطاع الخاص وغيره يعني الحوار مع اتحاد
الشغل لم ينقطع والاتحاد بطبيعه الحال وجد
نفسه مضطرا للدخول من جديد فيما يسمى
بالصيحه النقابيه التي يريد منها شانا
سياسيا ان الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
هدات 25 جويليه 2021 لم ينح الى الجهه
التي يجب ان ينحاز اليها حتى لا يجد نفس
نفسه في هذه الوضعيه الان المعزوله في
علاقه بالسلطه يوم 25 جويلي عوض ان ينحاز
الى الديمقراطيه انحاز الى الانقلاب دعني
اقول بين ظفرين وبالتالي وجد نفسه اليوم
معزولا وضعيفا لا يستطيع ان يدافع عن
منظوريه علينا ان نحدد السبب الرئيسي
والاسباب الثانويه هي الان على امتداد
سنتين ضحيه لتسلط حكم انفرادي لا يريد ان
يتحرك احد في هذه البلاد الا صوت السلطه
الحاكمه هذا امر اساسي ان على المعارضه
كان عليها بعد 25 جيليا ان تراجع نفسها ان
تطرح على نفسها اسئله لماذا يعني فشل
الانتقال الديمقراطي لماذا وقع انقلاب 25
جويليه علينا ان نجدد انفسنا علينا ان
نجدد افكارنا على امتداد سنتين كنا نواجه
سلطه منفرده
بالراي حتى الذين قالوا لها نعم نحن معك
في تصحيح المسار ابعدتهم ولم تتحاور معهم
مما يعني في اخر التحليل ان هذه السلطه لم
تترك الان للمعارضه فرصه ان تقدم رؤاها
وتصوراتها وحتى نقدها الذاتي المعارضه
بدات تتناقش لكي تصل الى الوحده اولا لكي
توقف عمليه الانقسام التي افشلت العشريه
لكي تراجع تصوراتها لكي تني بدائلها ولكن
السلطه بطبيعه الحال لم
تملها